[Music]
oh that's a pretty shot from north
carolina this morning we welcome you
back to cbs morning's professional race
car driver bubba wallace is a champion
on the track and leader in the fight for
racial justice go bubba wallace as the
only black driver in nascar's cup series
he's been an advocate for more diversity
in the predominantly white sport a new
netflix docu-series it's called race
bubba wallace is taking viewers behind
the scenes on his journey to make rice
racing rather more inclusive in this
clip he tells journalist mel hill
he talks about what's at stake here's a
look
when you're the only one
everything that you do is under a
microscope
they're using that to justify whether or
not you even belong
[Applause]
what do i think about myself yeah i'm
just the same as everybody else
we're just drivers at the end of the day
and i'm going to win
he's ready to win and he does that bubba
wallace joins us now bubba good morning
it's really good to see you we've been
nate and i've been talking about you all
morning looking forward to this listen
it's six parts bubba i intended to watch
one part
and then i got so drawn and that's the
beauty of netflix it goes next next next
and before you knew it i had watched all
six episodes so bravo bravo to you you
know it's interesting to see
oh you're welcome you're welcome and
we're here to sing the praises you know
it's interesting to watch your evolution
i heard your mom say once that bubba
never intended to be an activist that
wasn't what he was trying to do
but things changed after the ahmad
arberry shooting it really it really
deeply affected you can you talk about
that
yeah for sure you know that still is a
is a tough subject to to speak on and to
think about um just you know
constantly thinking about his family but
just seeing that video and and you know
thinking of how far we've stooped as a
as a
human
to be able to
go through and follow with that was just
very unsettling for me and so it was
time for change
it was time to speak up and and and be
some somebody who
who can try to make good change in in
the spotlight that i'm in so it's been a
it's been a lot of work which is part of
it and
i've i've not regretted one thing since
uh since that day
bubba good to see you again now in 2020
you asked nascar to ban the confederate
flags they did and you also drove a
black lives matter car what other
changes would you like to see nascar
make
honestly you know that's a that's a good
question we're having
conversations
weekly daily
on what we can do
to be better
and i think you know with everything
that's going on this year with our next
gen car
uh the racing has been
pretty good i would say i keep asking
you know my fiance is at every race and
i'm saying how's the racing going and
even seeing um you know fans from the
stands there their uh conversations
about the races has been really good so
our sport is trimming upward for on
track stuff and then you know what we
were able to do with the clash out the
coliseum out in la was really cool
totally different environment that we've
ever been in and uh 70
uh of the ticket sales were first time
comers to a tour nascar race so i
thought that was pretty cool and so um
it's it's special the demographic is
definitely changing the the vibe is
definitely changing with nascar so we're
taking it all in we're learning what we
can do to be better and to have that
exact answer i don't really know
but that's the fun part that that keeps
us working that keeps us pushing to do
better and better you know once you do
have an answer then like all right then
what's after that it's like i don't know
the unknown is what is what gets me
excited so we got to keep working
you know listen bubba when you talk
about the vibe is different i now want
to go to a nascar race and i never
wanted to go before i started following
you and i'm not kidding i'm i'm actually
thinking about coming later this month
we're going to we're going to make that
happen we can make that happen yes
i put her in the car i'm actually
thinking about coming take her around
this is the thing i don't think people
understand the athleticism that's
involved when you're in that car it's
very hot you lose a lot of weight and
it's it's it's more than just driving a
car round and round and round and i
think people need to understand the
athleticism of what you guys do in that
car can you talk about that for a second
and bubba how you hate to lose most
athletes do but then you started trash
talking yourself you got so down on
yourself
yeah i'm i am my own worst critic uh you
know when i make a mistake um
you know i'm super hard on myself and
sometimes it's okay to have a little bit
of self motivation but when when you
stoop as low as i do it's it's tough to
climb back out of but i think i've i've
graduated from that point in my life
hopefully i haven't made a big enough
mistake to let mine tell me otherwise
yet so
um but you know it's it's a lot to be a
race car driver i mean you get you get a
glimpse of what it's like and that's
what i wanted to showcase for everybody
tuning in
is we didn't really hold back on
anything um i want to show you how
mentally physical
emotionally everything draining
that the sport is and what it takes to
be successful so uh there's always
people out there that nascar is in a
sport well you get to see otherwise uh
in the stocky series and um you know it
like you said we get to we lose weight
at just about every race that means we
eat good monday through saturday so it's
nice to let it all back out
you talked candidly about your
depression which i thought was really
very very powerful when you talked about
that you talked about estrangement from
your father i really am hoping that the
two of you work it out really we're all
cheering for you on that but your mom
man she's in the she's in the
documentary the whole time she's
knockout and clearly a big big bubba
wallace fan
yeah no doubt and to be honest with you
um you know the donkey series just came
out
and uh shortly after i received a text
message from my father a very positive
text message so
that was that was surprised me but uh i
was uh my family and i were praying for
it so
we're i think we're starting to rekindle
um i'm so glad to hear that
i'm so glad to hear that
bubba you all you say that listen every
time you get in the car you know it
could be the last time but you get in
that car and you have no fear please
know that we are cheering you on
cheering that's right i appreciate it
and i'm serious we're gonna make you
come out to a race we're gonna get you
out there and have the best of time
well right now i'm looking at march 20th
in georgia just thinking just thinking
that's soon i love it let's make it
happen
thank you so much and nate bubbawella's
place of drums
that was the man bubba wallace plays the
drums i just have to have a drum set
that's there's a big difference
all right you can watch race bubba
wallace on netflix